me
none
[音楽]
私はございません
いっ
大手食べる前で4台
よろしければ食べれば日経ちゃったよ
あの我々が何で今日この2人で登壇してるかと言うと今ちょっと紹介にもありました
けれども5年前ですね
tx 2014でそれぞれ別のですね
登壇者として別々に登壇しました
で山地さんは
ロケットの話私はもう北極の話をしたんですけども
絵は控室控えしたろうねですね
あのちょうど私あの
here 長調じゃあ
アクセル間に私の sony って作れないですかねみたいな話を振ったら面白い
そこ少年っていう感じでや北後でちっちゃい頃にですね
あ分センサーとスコットさんの電球読んでましたから南極探検と関わりたいという
気持ちもあったので
段階で作れたらいいなって思ったってそうですねほんとにその雑談がきっかけになって
実勢じゃそれを作りましょうって話なりましたでへその結果去年の1月に私が南極点
まで
この写真なんですけども無補給単独歌一人で南極点まで行った時のは映ってる総理
をこれがし1号機かなっちゃうわけですねで今年の春
若者たちとちょうどこのそれも実際
カ月間たものですカナダの北極圏は600基の一か月かけて歩いたんですけども
その時に使ったそりを作っていただいたということですね子ちゃんっ
そうですねこれ実物ですね
ブーブーであのー私がティモノっ女性が稼ぐダンボールでそれ作ったことあー
朝日ちょっとダンボールでね総局はなかなかいけるんだけども
あのロケットとかでこういうなんかファルン
助手はで使ったことあったんだけどもそのこういう形母がポッと空いてるっていうのを
作ったことなくてつつはね作りやすいですよ
難しいなぁと思ったしか僕最初にですね皆さんに
軽さが必要なカーボンがいいんじゃないのって言ったらいきなりカーブも否定されまし
たもんねそうですね
あの我々カーボンはダメなんですなぜかっていうとカーボンて軽量で強いってイメージ
があるじゃないさ
色気っていうかねよく使っていますしカーボンってあの
低温になるとはれるように砕けるんですね
特にをピンポイントの商品が終わった時にしなかったんですよね
そうするとねこういうソリになれば100キロの荷物を積んでマイナス50度ぐらいの
中でこの100キロが氷の時とかに当たるとそこがパリッと割れるんですねか本ダメな
んです
bouvet にそれづくりを進めた時にエロそぶー橋も a パティどういう素材を
作ればで作ればいいかあっでもう一から試行錯誤からスタート
ただもんね入れませんで一番最初に行ったのが工業試験場
これ札幌ですよねそうですね
これウすごくねあのいい測定器いっぱいあるんですよ
すごいやすく実験サポートしてくれるんですよね僕らも今までいろんな実験でこの試験
場さんには随分お世話になっていてそのご縁でね今回のこの
それ作る時の材質の音試験もこいねお願いしたら快く引き受けてくれました
あのいくつか候補の a
素材を持ち込んだんですねいわゆるこれ frp っていう素材ってくれていますが
プラスチックなんですけども
元はほんと布みたいな繊維系の素材なんですねそれを樹脂で固めてこういうふうに硬く
なる
その樹脂であったりとかその繊維系の素材は何がどういう素材が適してるんだろうと
いうことを
マホに工業試験場に持ち込んで加工機械で要求を押して
に触れのなニュートンではれたとかね
あと
機械の中をマイナス50度に冷やしてその中で同じような私はだと力をかけて
っていう機械がここにあるんですよねこの機会がね珍しい貴重品なんですよ
マイナス50度まできますよ試験装置はどこでもあるんだけどね低音にできるっていう
のは泣かなくてねやさすが北海道っていう感じそういう座れないですね
でまずここに持って行っていろんな素材をため
して一応カーボン思っていたんですそれでカーボン張ってダメなんですよ
ある瞬間までは頑張るんですけど
ある瞬間を超え確かにパキッとも強度がゼロになるんですね
他の素材はカーボンよりも早く落ちるんだけども
07ないです
これぐらいで止まるんですね
そっちの方が大事なんですねカーボンは完全に粉々になってしまうので使いがい
まあこういう実験を繰り返してありましたここに耐摩耗性のですね s と何かあり
ましたらお願いして
でその後にコンピュータ冗長で
モデルを作るんですね設計をしますでその設計の通りに
起爆をつくって
木枠を組んで
発泡スチロールを
組み込んでそれを削るんですねそうするとああ
処理のような形になるんですねはいこれ何使っていうかと一人作ってるわけじゃないん
です実はねソリの形をつくってますこの中部をつくってんですよなかなか事方もなカゴ
を作ってるんですよ
あのた入れてみたいなもんでタイヤて作る前にある方いるじゃないですか
たい焼きの方がねまず肩をつくる作業ですね
でも私も一緒にいたですね4日今日も一生懸命言ってましたね
ねこのも入れになりますもんねようですね自分でねお時間作れる時はなるべく明るい
ですねえませんきって一緒に作業をやったんですけどもで買った方ができるんです
この方に
その繊維素材を貼り付けて手本に樹脂いって固めるとこうなるんですねこれが
これですねっ
でそこにいろんな付属品ですねもう散ってとかカバー
そうですね引くための金具のかそういうものをつけるとそれが完成しますまあこういう
プロセスを踏んでこの処理っていうのは完成してるですね
で
まあそもそも
上間さんあの
私が頼んだじゃないですかうん
それ作れないでそうですねで結構即答であやりましょうっていう音ちょーでしたね
でもう私はわかってたんですけど
経験のないかったよねですねうん
なんで受けたんですか
なったく僕と同じ4帯びているような人なんじゃないかなっていう気がしたんですよ
追ってね引き受けたらきっといいことあるなぁと思ったんです
ど太鼓とかそうですねただ僕らみたいな製造業も後サービス業もそうだと思うんです
けどもやっぱりより良くを求めていきたいんですよ
良いサービスをやっていきたいですもうしも僕たちが
一生懸命頑張って工夫していいものを作ってもいやそんな余計な事しなくていいから
さーとこの撮る上の友達をつくってくれていいんだと安くすればいいんだてるのはもう
おしまいなんですよ
発展できなくなっちゃうまたは一緒に共同研究して作ってるはずが使って b て壊れ
たぞとどうすんだと賠償請求だとかってくれるよ
れてもやっぱり成田とないんですね
残念ながら今の日本ではですねこの責任の追及が変な方向入っているせいでみんなが
責任を回避しようと思って
誰も工夫ができなくなっちゃってる感じがしてですねそれがすっごい嫌だなぁと思って
て
うちの場面と言えば日本中で使ってもらえてるんですけども実はそれを支えてくれて
いるがお客さんでやっぱりまぐれば壊れた後の時に賠償だじゃなくてどうして壊れたん
だろうと
どうやったらこうれいむがあるんだろうって言ってくれたお客さんと一緒に成長してき
たんですね
a それがきっとみなさんもきっとそのパターンだなぁと思ってですね
で引き受けてみたらうちの会社の子たちがものすごい成長してくれてですいやーほんと
これはお金で買える感じではないなと思って
目的に大冒険ですこれ私あの
南極の処理も作ってもらいましたしこのソリも十五六で作ってるんですよ
私あの
1円も払ってないんですよ
結構かかってなさんすよ材料費から工業試験場で
で使う実験するお金であるとかそういうこと社員さんをね
だいぶ時間使ってますけど願っています私 i もらってなくて一応やって言ったん
ですよ難局を張った後に
6材料費ぐらいはご飯を支配しますので請求してくださいって言ったら僕たちが作った
それよね
南極点まで持っていってくれてありがとうございますってお金はキャリイでしょうって
言ってくれて
まぁちょっとちょっと涙出そうになったけどもう here まあその心意気というか
ね
なんかそれすごくいい
本当に嬉しかったですねやでも自分が作ったそりがめんべいの前にあった者が弾極点に
あるんですよ
普通なかなかそんなこと起きないですからねそれを猫 a
チャンスをくれたということとぱそこで使えたよっていう実績ですよてょどんどん壊れ
ないっ割と簡単作れるんですよ
間違い応募いいんですっ
それも作った本人だとはここをこうやったら壊れるよねってわかっているから加減して
使ってくれると軽くて強いものになるんだなぁと思ってですねそれができたら皆さんが
毎回毎回来てくれてね一緒に作ってくだかなぁと思っているそうですね私も
だから正直植松さんが frp の専門家じゃないのは初めからわかってましたし
すごかったんですよで打ち合わせ行った時もさあどうしようかねえ力いいですね
それから打ち合わせが始まりですよ何からやろうかなって
これが私が例えばもうこういう音 frp を成形する専門の会社って日本に
たらですよ
そういうもうすでにノウハウがあって素材の知識も豊富なところに発注してこういう
ふうに作ってくださいって言ったらその通り寸分違わず
希望のものが私の目の前にある日突然解けされてくるんですよね
でもねそれじゃあなんかやなんですよねそれだと
自分のアイディアがなぁ
アイデアは込められているんだけど自分の手が入ってない感じがするというか結局お金
で買ってきた物っていうのは
誰がどのように作ってるかが見えないので
この処理は私も手を入れているので例えばこの部分はちょっと肉厚だなとかここはあ
に強度が足りないなぁとかわかってるわけですよそうすると結局それが現場で安全性に
繋がるんですね
こういう使い方したら壊れやすいと
ここまでだったら耐えられるとかそういうのは全部わかるので結果いいものを
望んで発注するんじゃなくてイチからという方もゼロから一緒に素材の段階から試行
錯誤して作りたいなと思ってるんで
植松さんだったらこんなねもう市販でいいものがあるんだったらもう金出して買って
くりゃいいじゃないのとは言わずに
同じ温度計あらっアティですね
不思議不思議な意気投合カーヌーン
その端なりましたねやっても edi でよかったですはい
で私も次
また北極点の挑戦も
チャレンジしていきたいなと書いてえっとまぁ2012年と2014年の2回
北極点の無補給単独ところというふうにチャレンジしてるんですけど途中までしか行け
ないですね一情報に難しいでしょうね
チャレンジなんですけども海の上を凍った海の上を行くんですね
そうすると
去年の南極点とか今年のこの北極の
このソリとはまたちょっと違った a
性能という価格であの
昨日が違うというかそうでしょうねはい
でまぁまだ私に見えまさにオフィシャルに入ってないんですけどちょっとその人に作っ
てもらっていいするあああああっはぁ
お願いですよあのねぇ
南極の初号機ってこの北極の2号機これはあくまでも次の本番の北極ラン票態度35
キーのための尺品でしかありませんので
どーんっ
あの北極点だと
かっこいいまでなってあった
それであのちょっと話が経過しますこの春のも曲ですねちょっと短いがよこんな風に
ですか
ちょっと前後しますかあったり仰りたいんだねー
ナイフを持ってるッ
でね北極海てこういう場所なんですねこれに俺がねーなー14年の北極点北極海ておき
海なんですね海の表面に氷があっている
方法2海の流氷と同じです流氷の上きくのと
ものは同じ調整透明の前でお湯にこり月に上がったらいいのか
追われて水になってたりするので割れ目は私ドライスーツっての着て泳いでは夢のよう
だった郡
我々が多い本協会の古典を教会で不快結構オフタイムを出すことで2500メートルが
移籍し使う訳じゃないですねサー
あの一人で負荷ポードライスーツれスーツ着ながらホントにもう一人ですよ
始まっ飛距離だもんな人に聞いたんだけどあのね浮きながらねあーことした2000
メートルぐらいコーミズ店とかね
考えるにフォトギャラワっとしていくんですけどそういう時によく
a ちゃんに持つどうするんですか
自分は泳ぎますとこれはこのそれはちょっと難しいんですけど
水にも服ように荷物を積んだまま水に浮いてボートみたいにそれがや水陸両用のそれに
作る必要があって実はその冷静の私が前に使ってるそう言ったらものすごい優秀な1人
なんですよ
ん
それはね綺麗に水に浮くんですね
それも何だろう可能
じゃあそれかっつかそれ使えばいいじゃんって話なんですよ行っちゃう
でもねぇ
すごい優秀すぎていっ
買ってきてそれを使うのがなんかねえ釈然としないんですよね変な人ばはいっぱい入っ
てるにわかりますね
いう主婦すぎてただ買ってきて
あ使い方し気になって使うのがねぇ気持ち悪いですよねぇー
いやわかるけどわからないけどわかるっっどうしたらいいかなぁと思ってなんか開いて
やってありますよやっぱり生かすっていうのもありますし
水床さぁやったら票対応で突破しなきゃないからね郡学校4メートルぐらい盛り上がっ
てるっちゃしたからねそうですね
今このソリ2台ありますので北極海だと処理を寝て2台で使うんです一人で
南極の場合はそり1台だったですなぜかというと南極は平らなんです大陸なんです
基本真っ平らなんで1個のそれに100球だいたい100キロぐらいの荷物になるん
ですけど100キロ積んでも平らなので
あのヘアーメイク直したあのだいあの問題なんですねずっと行けるんですったらこう
いう壁のような本当にこの天井ぐらいにた重なったりすることなんです郡
風がこんなところ100キロの荷物一人で
越せないでしょ
無理なんですよ
そうすると100キロ2つに分散して50キロ50票なのか694需給にして1個ずつ
運ばないと一人じゃ到底無理なんですね
でこれが例えばチーム複数2人以上になると1人100キロの荷物でも1個のソリを
一緒に運んでくれる人がいるので一人100キロでいいんでしょ
そこに2つになると2度手間じゃなくて3度で学びますああ
あります2つのソリを一人で運ぶと橇そりに子ですよ
1個運ぶ自分がモデルもういっぱいって戻っていくっていう同じところをね
3回登録必要があるんですなるほどなろう
だからねどっちが効率的なのでしょ a
頭一個だと重すぎるし
それ自体も軽くしなきゃないけれども言動もあるからね空に浮かすとかおかしいんです
かね
浮かせられますかね違う踏力使って行ければ登録使うといえば座面量もいるんですよね
あるのかっていうね色んな問題も出てきて北極の端っこからだーって言っちゃうって
言われつけてもまあそうですねあるところなんだけど急にからなきゃながらた切り気に
ならないけどどうしたらいいのかなーってねえよ
はまだ全然分もかなり悩んでる野鳥じゃないですね卜部荻田さんを何北極点に行かせ
たいんです
[拍手]
そろそろ時間ですほんとだ気がついたら終わった10秒しか洗いたいですね
あのこれ以上収めると鈴木さんに怒られちゃいますのであの
続きはちょっと打ち合わせはアクやて隠れて
ございます今日はありがとうございましたん
[拍手]